- If I just want to like
dip my toe in the whole like
Marie Kondo thing like could
I do it like, what do you do?
It takes six months?
- Okay, well you don't
have to go full Kondo.
Let's easy win.
- I am an extremist Beth.
- Are you?
- I am not a half-asser
- Then , you might wanna start..
I was gonna suggest you
start with the bathrooms
because those drawers are usually easier.
Be like, junk, junk
- I have so much junk in there
- Makeup, products, so did I,
- People send me stuff, yes
- So thank you for
sending me these and now
it will go to my sister.
- Bye
- Yeah, and then she can Kondo her house.
(laughs) impossible.
- I'm gonna do that.
- But do, cause I think Marie
has her set way of doing it
but I think if you start small
and easier way and you'll be,
you'll be addicted, it
kind of gets addicting.
- Okay, so here's what we'll
do, I can't do this alone
people, I want help.
- So if you're watching and
you have a messy bathroom,
like I do, let's commit to
doing this together, okay?
Take a before photo of
your bathroom this week,
post it, I have that I'm
forcing, I'm asking you
so I'm gonna have to do this. (laughs)
- It will change your
life, all of you do it.
- Post it on Instagram
with @thekellyclarksonshow
and #KellyKondobefore you
know and I'll do it too.
- You have to now, you
just put it out there so..
- I just promised the world
- Marie is watching.
- Now I'm a liar if I don't.
- She's no joke man
- All right, well this
month you got a Kondo
that sucker all right.
And sometime before Halloween,
post your after photo
with @thekellyclarksonshow
and #KellyKondoafter.
Get what we're doing there? (laughs)